ce soir on va aussi revenir sur la
lettre ouverte de Gérard Depardieu pour
rappel Gérard Depardieu est mise en
examen depuis 2020 pour des soupçons de
viols et d'agression sexuelle sur la
comédienne Charlotte ARN des faits qu'il
conteste bien sûr formellement Gérard on
va voir cet extrait sur cnews et on va
vous lire la lettre bien entendu qui a
écrit Gérard Depardieu et Myriam Palomba
nous y dira un petit peu plus dans un
instant tout de suite regardez
ah vas-y
les mecs
Gérard Depardieu prend la plume et
réfute ses accusations jamais au grand
jamais je n'ai abusé d'une femme faire
du mal à une femme ce serait comme
donner des coups de pied dans le ventre
de ma propre mère le comédien provoquant
débordant et parfois grossier comme il
se décrit se défend affirmant que la
relation avec Charlotte Arnaud était
consentie sur les allégations d'emprise
qu'il aurait exercé sur la plaignante
Gérard Depardieu dénonce un lynchage
orchestré par les médias comme la
comédienne 13 femmes ont également
témoigné contre lui pour des faits
similaires merci Myriam d'être avec nous
merci vous avez ramené les beaucoup de
feuilles je sais pas si vous allez vous
avez plus travailler que toutes les
équipes réunissent Myriam Myriam
pouvez-vous nous rappeler de quoi est
accusé enfin alors depuis le 16 décembre
2020 Gérard Depardieu est acc est mis en
examen pour agression sexuelle et viol
et fait remontent en fait à août 2018 ou
une jeune actrice qui s'appelle
Charlotte Arnoux l'accuse d'avoir abusé
d'elle dans son hôtel particulier
parisien alors elle a raconté sa version
des faits regardez
il veut savoir où j'en suis au niveau de
la danse du piano enfin c'est assez
banal et donc je me rends chez lui et au
bout de devant assez rapidement tout
bascule ou l'accusez de vous avoir violé
oui presque une semaine après je sais
qu'il s'est passé quelque chose de grave
le 7 août vraiment je me dis je suis
morte ma vie est finie enfin c'est
vraiment je l'incarne enfin ces mots là
deviennent moi enfin moi je me sens
morte tout le monde sait tout le monde
sait qui se comporte comme ça sur les
tournages donc personne n'est surpris et
pourtant il y a ce truc mais c'est
Gérard il y a des gens qui permettent
que ce soit possible c'est à dire que
oui c'est tous ces gens qui sont au
pouvoir nourrissent le monstre aussi
dans un instant vous allez voir la
lettre ouverte qui écrit Gérard
Depardieu dans le Figaro mais alors donc
ça ce sont des c'était des faits qui
remontent à 2018 c'est ça 2018 en fait
il connaissait les parents de Charlotte
depuis de longues années il lui a
proposé début ou de venir réviser une
pièce de théâtre et puis à la suite de
de qu'elle est venue chez lui et puis au
bout de quelques minutes après avoir
parlé longue enfin parler de théâtre il
se sera approché d'elle et lui aurait
demandé de la version de il faut faire
là
après je dis pas que c'est vrai non non
on est d'accord parce qu'après en plus
il y a des éléments qui quand même sont
assez contradictoires et troublant donc
effectivement
ce qu'elle ce qu'elle raconte c'est que
voilà il aurait abusé d'elle à une
première fois et puis elle aurait elle
aurait vu une deuxième fois de son plein
gré et il y aurait eu à nouveau une
agression sexuelle alors ce qui est un
peu bizarre c'est qu'il y a une première
plainte qui a été déposée qui a été
classé sans suite sauf que une juge
d'instruction c'est en part et de la
plainte parce qu'elle sait pas la
victime présumée s'est posée en partie
civile et du coup la juge d'instruction
a estimé qu'il y avait des faits assez
graves pour pour que la plainte soit
constituée d'autant plus que la
personnalité psychologique de Charlotte
qui est anorexique et compliqué et que
ça peut être ça veut pas dire que non
mais comme c'est une circonstance
aggravante du coup la juge d'instruction
a décidé de s'emparer de la faire
aujourd'hui donc Gérard Depardieu vous
nous avez dit qu'il y avait deux trois
deux trois infos qui que les pas c'est
quoi bah oui parce
que dans l'hôtel particulier il y a des
caméra et les vidéos ont montré que la
jeune fille était repartie de de de
l'hôtel parisien la première fois avec
le sourire elle rigolait même donc c'est
vrai que ça contredit un peu sa version
en plus elle lui a envoyé quand même un
texto où elle lui dit mon doux Gérard
j'ai appris la pièce de théâtre Parker
est-ce qu'on peut se revoir et puis
surtout elle a aussi envoyé un mail à
l'ami qu'ils avaient en commun à savoir
faire Fanny Ardant où elle où elle
pétrit des Loges Gérard Depardieu donc
c'est vrai que c'est assez troublant sa
réaction après l'effet qu'elle dit aide
être des agressions sexuelles et voire
même des viols Gérard Depardieu la
lettre ouverte de Gérard Depardieu et la
publier une lettre aujourd'hui Gérard
dans laquelle ils savent son innocence à
nos accusations d'agressions sexuelles à
son encontre comment s'en expliquant que
j'ai ce que ces accusations ont eu un
impact direct sur sa carrière je croyais
m'en [__] mais non en fait non tout
cela matin pire encore metin aujourd'hui
tu ne peux plus chanter Barb ara parce
qu'une femme qui voulait chanter Barbara
avec moi m'accusé de viol
jamais au grand jamais je n'ai abusé
d'une femme
faire du mal à une femme ce serait comme
donner des coups de pied dans le ventre
de ma propre mère
une femme est venue chez moi une
première fois le palais gym on tend de
son plein gré dans ma chambre elle dit
aujourd'hui et avoir été violée
elle est revenue une seconde fois
il n'y a jamais eu entre nous ni
contrainte ni violence ni protestations
elle voulait chanter avec moi les
chansons de Barbara au Cirque d'Hiver je
lui ai dit non
elle a déposé plainte
alors me dit-on elle était sous emprise
mais on est tous en prison
moi-même je suis sous emprise on ADN la
famille la société l'argent le spectacle
l'alcool et le cinéma qui ont fait de
moi une nature
si elle a été sous emprise c'était sous
sa propre emprise elle n'a jamais été
sous mon emprise
j'ai été durant toute ma vie provocant
débordant parfois grossier
j'ai fait souvent ce que personne n'ose
faire tester les limites bousculer
certitude et sur un plateau entre deux
prises entre deux tensions rire
tout le monde à Paris
si penses survivre intensément le
présent j'ai blessé choqué qui que ce
soit j'ai jamais pensé à faire de mal et
je vous prie de m'excuser de m'être
comporté comme un enfant qui va amuser
la galerie
mais je ne suis ni un violeur
ni un prédateur
je suis juste un homme et je suis aussi
une femme qui chante et qui chante une
femme Barbara
voire qu'on sert après concert des
extrémistes sans regard brandir des
camps pancartes cale au mieux souillez
vandalisés
interrompre en hurlant les chansons de
Barbara cette femme hautement féministe
c'est l'enterrer à nouveau
désormais je ne peux plus faire entendre
sa voix
oui elle a réagi elle vient de donner
une interview magazine Elle dans le dans
laquelle elle dit que c'est un message
vraiment immonde elle dit il m'a souillé
en 2018 et d'une certaine façon il
continue de le faire parler les mots
c'est une sais-tu pour elle c'est une
nouvelle stratégie de communication de
Gérard Depardieu qui doit se sentir
acculé dit-elle par la perspective d'un
procès alors Gilles alors ce que ce
qu'il faut dire c'est quand même c'est
que lui il se défend de tout
comportement pénalement répréhensible ça
c'est important depuis le début et lui
il plaide la relation consentie voilà et
comme vous l'avez lu Cyril ni contrainte
ni violence alors pourquoi il fait cette
lettre c'est parce que il ne peut plus
travailler concrètement c'est à son
spectacle sur Barbara il y a eu des
dates annulées il y a des gens qui
commencent à ne plus vouloir venir et
quand il produit son spectacle il y a
des associations féministes qui me
brandissent des pancartes et très forte
sa lettre est très émouvante très forte
c'est maintenant très franchement je
vais pas dire paroles contre parole mais
il y a deux versions totalement
contradictoires et totalement opposé ça
va pas être facile pour la juge de
démêler le vrai du faux dans cette
histoire montent à 2018
50 et lui en fait il plaide c'est
implicite mais c'est que la jeune femme
revient voilà ça ça défend c'est basé
là-dessus elle revient la deuxième fois
à deux reprises en plus ça lui envoie
des SMS elle envoie des mails donc c'est
vrai que c'est un peu ça ce qui va lui
permettre de de se défendre par rapport
à ces assez fait dénoncé et la deuxième
fois sa mère à elle qu'il avait
encouragé à aller voir deux parties amis
de la famille au début la deuxième fois
sa mère lui dit ben n'y va pas et elle y
va quand même voilà donc il y a ces
interrogations et c'est ces auditions à
elle qui permettront peut-être d'y voir
plus clair Siri justement qui est
Charlotte Arnoux la jeune fille qui
accuse de Gérard Depardieu elle connaît
très bien la famille de de Gérard oui
oui en fait c'est
une jeune fille qui à la base je voulais
être danseuse et qui finalement décide
de devenir actrice et elle profite que
ses parents qui qui connaît Gérard
Depardieu pour prendre contact avec avec
lui sachant qu'elle le connaît depuis
son plus jeune âge sur le père de
Charlotte a effectivement des hôtels
dans une célèbre station suisse et il
s'y rendait régulièrement donc il
connaît Charlotte depuis très très
longtemps maintenant la la relation
entre les parents de Charlotte et de
c'est conflictuels ils ont pris oui
c'est conflictuels se parlent plus du
tout donc ils ont pris évidemment la
défense de leur fille alors aujourd'hui
Géraldine qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
la lettre de Gérard Depardieu moi je
suis par plein de sentiments un peu
contradictoires d'abord je trouve que la
libération de la parole des femmes ça a
été c'est très très important il faut
comme l'a dit tout à l'heure Valérie
globalement quand les femmes parlent ben
en fait c'est globalement vrai même si
dernièrement il y a eu beaucoup
d'histoires ou horrible enfin je veux
dire elle s'attaque à un mastodonte à un
ogre un monstre non ça veut rien dire
mais malgré tout je trouve que c'est
quand même je me dis que c'est quand
même ça doit être un besoin pour elle je
ne sais pas qui est quand même très fort
après moi ça me gêne toujours
aujourd'hui je trouve que le tribunal
médiatique s'empare de ce sujet enquête
sur cette jeune fille aussi ou pas
psychologues qui ont dit que
effectivement il y avait elle se
protégeait émotionnellement mais qui
avait pas d'affabulation de sa part
après il y a peu d'hommes qui ont dit
oui moi je j'ai violé donc dans les
lettres c'est rare quand même ce qu'elle
a gagné si on écoute Gérard Depardieu
donc non seulement elle aurait menti
mais selon lui il lui aurait refusé une
opportunité professionnel ce qui
expliquerait qu'elle se venge c'est ça
la version
la semaine dernière Gilles c'est un peu
un cas similaire oui alors elle veut
chanter Barbara avec lui voilà c'est ça
son objectif à elle c'est de chanter le
spectacle en 2018 il devait les chansons
de Barbara d'accord bah c'est ce qu'elle
laisse un album en 2016 et il entamé une
une tournée 2017 et elle elle voulait
chanter avec lui au Cirque d'Hiver ça ne
se fait pas pour diverses raisons que
l'on connaît pas encore et il ne l'a
choisi pas et du coup lui dit du coup
elle se venge voilà d'accord c'est sa
thèse d'accord donc aujourd'hui ça on
est bon alors aujourd'hui l'enquête
l'enquête se poursuit il y a eu il y a
eu confrontation ils ont été reçus l'un
et l'autre et pour l'instant les avocats
de de Gérard Depardieu le défendre ce
qui est ce qui est ce qui est un peu
compliqué pour Gérard Depardieu c'est
que il a décidé là son agent vient de
parler de refuser tout projet
professionnel tant que ces accusations
ne seront pas démontées il faut savoir
quand même que là il risque jusqu'à 20
ans de réclusion criminelle parce que
ils estiment qu'il y a effectivement des
circonstances aggravantes notamment le
fait que cette jeune fille était malade
et qu'elle était anorexique et que donc
on pouvait avoir une emprise
psychologique sur elle on va voir la
languette se continue évidemment ok
merci en tout cas